President Trump is in France where he
may answer more questions about his sons
meeting with a Russian lawyer during the
campaign the president is meeting this
morning with French president and Manuel
McCrone in Paris the senior
administration official said they
discussed Syria counterterrorism and
possibly the recent g20 summit mr. Trump
will also be the guest of honor at a
Bastille Day celebration tomorrow it is
a sign the two leaders may be getting a
little more friendly after their
contentious first meeting ahead of the
NATO summit including that handshake
nearly two months ago Mark Phillips is
in Paris with the presidents who have
something in common mark good morning
good morning well when the French
president invited the American went to
Paris it was to commemorate two
anniversaries but this visit is also
about the continuing contest of wills
between two leaders who are in some way
similar in others so different it's a
relationship that started with the
famous handshake the grasp wasn't just
to show friendship between leaders it
was more like an arm wrestling contest
prepared the handshake and oh that he
had not only thought about it but
prepared for it
Francois he's Berg is a foreign affairs
expert with the Paris think-tank what
was he trying to to prove one is that
he's able to do the job
the other thing that he's trying to to
do is to demonstrate to the world that
France is back on the face of it
president Trump's brief visit here is in
connection with the French national
holiday and the big parade tomorrow and
it's about commemorating the arrival of
US troops in the first world war a
hundred years ago an arrival that helped
end the stalemate in the trenches and
win the war but the visit is full of
meaning for today the two presidents are
similar and that they both broke the
mould of establishment politics but
their approach to the world's problems
could not be more different macro is an
internationalist believing in free trade
and a collective approach across borders
and not only in combating climate change
he was the most outspoken critic of
Donald Trump's decision to withdraw from
the Paris Accords and their attempt to
limit global warming
make our planets great again inviting
the US president to Paris was not just a
gesture of thanks for America's role in
a war a hundred years ago it's being
seen here as an attempt despite what
Donald Trump has said to keep the United
States engaged after their meeting here
today the two presidents will hold a
brief press encounter just two questions
aloud to each president we're told this
may be Paris but Jeff will see whether
the president's domestic concerns have
followed him here Mark Phillips in Paris
thank you very much